♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
RELIEF IS FINALLY HERE.
AFTER TENSE NEGOTIATIONS AND
MULTIPLE ROUNDS OF TELEVISED
THEATRICS, THE CONGRESS HAS
PASSED A DEFINITIVE SPENDING
BILL.
IT’S 5,593 PAGES LONG AND
AMOUNTS TO $2.3 TRILLION.
THAT INCLUDES NEARLY A TRILLION
DOLLARS IN COVID RELIEF.
ALL OF THAT COMES RIGHT FROM THE
U.S. TREASURY, WHICH IS BUSY
PRINTING IT RIGHT NOW.
THAT’S A LOT OF MONEY.
ON THE OTHER HAND, THERE’S A LOT
OF NEAT.
THANKS IN PART TO GOVERNMENT
MARKDOWNS, MORE THAN 100 MILLION
AMERICANS ARE OUT OF THE
WORKFORCE TONIGHT.
ONE AND SIX RESTAURANTS IS
CLOSED.
HUGE PARTS OF THE RETAIL SECTORS
ARE IN TATTERS.
J.CREW IN BANKRUPTCY, PIER ONE,
NEIMAN MARCUS, BROOKS BROTHERS,
CENTURY 21, AND MANY OTHERS.
SO, IF THERE EVER IS A TIME THAT
AMERICANS NEEDED RELIEF, IT WAS
RIGHT NOW.
SO BE GLAD TO KNOW, THERE IS
SOMETHING FOR YOU IN THIS BILL.
IT IS ENTIRELY POSSIBLE THAT YOU
COULD GET A $600 CHECK COURTESY
OF THE U.S. CONGRESS.
THAT MONEY, SHOULD YOU RECEIVE
IT, IS YOURS TO KEEP.
DO WHAT YOU WISH.
BUY A MODERATELY SIZED
TELEVISION SET AND WATCH THE
FREE CHANNELS.
ALL MIGHT COME IF YOU WANT.
RENT A TESLA FOR A DAY AND DRIVE
IT UNTIL THE POWER RUNS OUT.
OR SPLURGE AND ORDERED TWO FULL
APPETIZERS AT THE RESTAURANT IN
NAPA, TIP NOT INCLUDED.
THE SKY’S THE LIMIT, GO CRAZY.
$600, ALL FOR YOU.
IT’S GOOD TO BE AN AMERICAN.
ON THE OTHER HAND, IT IS ALSO
GOOD TO BE A JORDANIAN.
THIS SAME BILL, PAST BUT NOT
READ BY THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS, ALLOCATES $500 MILLION
FOR BORDER SECURITY IN JORDAN.
THAT’S ENOUGH CASH TO BUY THE
FRENCH LAUNDRY IN NAPA, A COUPLE
TIMES OVER.
BUT THAT IS NOT WITH THE MONEY
IS FOR.
CONGRESS WANTS TO HELP JORDAN
BUILD A WALL ALONG ITS 275-MILE
LONG BORDER WITH SYRIA.
APPARENTLY, CONGRESS IS WORRIED
ABOUT ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION OVER
THERE, AND YOU CAN SEE WHY.
THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS
ILLEGAL, AND THAT IS BAD.
THAT’S WHY CONGRESS ALLOCATED
ANOTHER QUARTER BILLION DOLLARS
FOR ADDITIONAL BORDER SECURITY,
IN LEBANON, EGYPT, TO ME SEE HER
HER, GOD KNOWS THOSE COUNTRIES
NEED IT.
BORDERS MAKE A NATION.
REMEMBER THAT.
ACCEPT HERE, IN THE
UNITED STATES, WHICH IS UNIQUE
AMONG NATIONS THROUGH HISTORY,
BORDERS ARE NOT RELEVANT.
IN FACT, PORTERS ARE RACIST.
THAT IS WHY THIS VERY SAME BILL,
WHICH DOES SO MUCH FOR THE
JORDANIANS AND EGYPTIANS AND
LEBANESE AND TUNISIANS, AND THE
PEOPLE OF OMAN, THE FUNDS
AMERICAN BORDER SECURITY.
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, WE
NEED THAT DEFUNDING.
THAT WAY WE WON’T BE BIG IT’S.
’S OF THE BILL SLASHES FUNDING
FOR ICE I.C.E. DETENTION --
EXCUSE ME.
IT CATCHES IN THE THROAT.
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES IN THIS
COUNTRY WILL HAVE -- I BEG YOUR
PARDON.
11,000 FEWER DETENTION BEDS
STARTING THIS YEAR.
AND IF THAT HURTS, IMAGINE ALL
OF THOSE PEOPLE MOVING HERE
PERMANENTLY.
THEY’LL HAVE TO.
PROBLEM SOLVED.
DOES NOT LIKE THEY’RE TRYING TO
SNEAK INTO JORDAN.
VERMONT SENATOR PATRICK LAHEY IS
EXCITED ABOUT THIS.
HE BRAGGED ABOUT IT IN A PRESS
RELEASE TODAY.
BUT THERE IS ALSO, YOU SHOULD
KNOW, $33 MILLION IN THE BILL
FOR WHAT ARE CALLED DEMOCRACY
PROGRAMS IN VENEZUELA, BECAUSE
WE ARE EXPERTS ON DEMOCRACY.
WE ARE SPENDING $231 MILLION TO
HELP PAY DOWN THE NATIONAL DEBT
OF SUDAN, AND OF COURSE, THAT IS
ANOTHER AREA OF EXPERTISE FOR
US, NATIONAL DEBT.
MEANWHILE, THE BILL, AND YOU
WANT TO KNOW THIS FOR CERTAIN,
SPENDS HUGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY TO
DIVERSIFY THE WORKFORCE IN OUR
SO-CALLED INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
THAT IS ANOTHER KEY NATIONAL
SECURITY OBJECTIVE.
AND JUST IN CASE YOU WERE
WORRIED THAT AMERICAN SOCIETY
WASN’T YET DIVIDED ENOUGH, THIS
BILL CREATES TWO NEW MONUMENTS
THE INTEREST GROUPS WITH THE
MOST POLITICAL POWER AT THE
MOMENT.
HENCEFORTH, THE SMITHSONIAN WILL
CREATE A WOMEN’S HISTORY MUSEUM,
AS WELL AS WHAT IS CALLED THE
NATIONAL MUSEUM OF THE AMERICAN
LATINO.
THAT IS JUST HERE IN AMERICA.
THERE’S A WHOLE LOT MORE FOR THE
REST OF THE WORLD.
THIS BILL SPENDS $10 MILLION ON
WHAT IT CALLS GENDER PROGRAMS IN
PAKISTAN.
CONGRESS DOES NOT SPECIFY
EXACTLY WHAT THOSE ARE.
LINDSEY GRAHAM SEEMS TO KNOW,
AND HE IS THRILLED ABOUT IT.
WATCH GRAM’S ENTHUSIASM THIS
MORNING.
>> PAKISTAN IS A PLACE I REALLY
WORRY ABOUT.
85 COUNTRIES, A WOMAN CAN’T OPEN
UP A BANK ACCOUNT WITHOUT HER
HUSBAND’S SIGNATURE.
SHE CAN’T INHERIT PROPERTY IF
YOU ARE YOUNG GIRL IN PAKISTAN,
LIFE IS PRETTY TOUGH,
SO THEY WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE
LIFE BETTER FOR WOMEN THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD.
>> Tucker: SO, LINDSEY GRAHAM
IS WORRIED ABOUT A LOT OF
THINGS, BUT HE’S REALLY WORRIED
ABOUT PAKISTAN.
HE’S NOT WORRIED ABOUT THE FACT
PAKISTAN HAS BUILT A VAST
NUCLEAR ARSENAL, THAT HAPPENED
DURING THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION.
GRAHAM WAS IN CONGRESS AT THE
TIME.
THAT’S A MINOR CONCERN GIVEN
THAT PAKISTAN IS AN UNSTABLE
COUNTRY IN A PERMANENT STATE OF
WAR WITH INDIA.
MOST STATESMEN CAN HANDLE THAT.
CONCERNS AND MOST, WHAT HE IS
"REALLY WORRIED ABOUT" IS THE
STATE OF GENDER ROLES IN
PAKISTAN.
NOW, GRAHAM, WHO HAS NEVER HAD A
FAMILY, NOW IMAGINES HE IS AN
EXPERT ON HOW THE PEOPLE OF A
COUNTRY, 7,000 MILES AWAY, WHOSE
LANGUAGE HE DOES NOT SPEAK,
WHOSE CULTURE HE DOES NOT
UNDERSTAND, SHOULD BE RUNNING
THEIR FAMILIES.
LINDSEY GRAHAM DOESN’T LIKE HOW
YOUNG PEOPLE, TWO EASILY
ACCEPTED CUSTOMS OF THEIR
ELDERS.
HE WOULD LIKE TO SHAKE THINGS UP
IN PAKISTAN SOCIETY, BIG IDEAS
OF HOW TO CREATE MORE
ENLIGHTENED URDU-SPEAKING
HOUSEHOLDS ON THE SUBCONTINENT,
AND HE IS GOING TO USE HER MONEY
TO DO IT.
WE ARE TRYING TO MAKE LIFE
BETTER FOR WOMEN THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD, GRAHAM ANNOUNCES, OF
COURSE HE IS CAPABLE OF DOING
THAT.
TAKE OUT THE TRASH, MAKE LIFE
BETTER FOR WOMEN THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD.
IT IS ALL IN A DAY’S WORK FOR AN
AMERICAN POLITICIAN.
OVERREACH, YOU SAY?
THESE ARE THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
CAN’T GET THE VOTES COUNTED IN A
CONGRESSIONAL ELECTION?
YEAH.
BUT THEY’VE GOT BIGGER
ASPIRATIONS THAN THAT.
AND THOSE ASPIRATIONS ARE ALL
OVER THIS SPENDING BILL.
ON ONE PAGE, YOU WILL FIND TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS SET ASIDE
TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN WOMEN IN
AFGHAN ARMY.
OKAY.
BUT WHY IS THE U.S. PAYING FOR
THIS?
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT WILL HELP
THE UNITED STATES IN SOME
MEASURABLE WAY?
WOULD HELP AFGHANISTAN?
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS?
WELL, THE REAL REASON CONGRESS
IS SPENDING THAT MONEY, OF
COURSE, BECAUSE CRAZED
IDEOLOGUES AND VARIOUS INTEREST
GROUPS IN THE FEDERAL
BUREAUCRACY WOULD LIKE TO CHANGE
ONE OF THE WORLD’S LAST
REMAINING TRADITIONAL SOCIETIES.
SOMEDAY, SOME UNHAPPY
26-YEAR-OLD AMERICAN FOREIGN
SERVICE OFFICER CAN WRITE HER
MASTERS THESIS IN GENDER STUDIES
ON HOW SHE UNDERMINES THE
PATRIARCHY IN SOUTHWEST ASIA.
THAT IS THE WHOLE POINT OF IT.
MEANWHILE, NO ONE IN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OR CONGRESS HAS PAUSE
TO THINK ABOUT WHAT THE AFGHANS
THINK.
THE VERY SAME PEOPLE WHO LECTURE
YOU ABOUT CULTURAL IMPERIALISM
THINK IT IS TOTALLY IRRELEVANT.
WHAT THE NATIVE POPULATION MIGHT
THINK OF THAT.
IN FACT, IT’S POSSIBLE THEY
MIGHT NOT CONSIDER IT AS
PROGRESS.
MAYBE THEY ARE HAPPY WITH THEIR
ANCIENT CULTURE, UNSAVORY AS WE
MAY FIND IT.
THAT CULTURE EXISTED A THOUSAND
YEARS BEFORE OURS ARRIVED.
MAYBE THEY WOULD LIKE TO KEEP
IT.
COME TO THINK OF IT, WHY WOULD
ANYONE PAKISTAN EVER TAKE ADVICE
FROM US ON HOW TO ORGANIZE A
SOCIETY?
YOU MUST ALLOW MARKET FORCES TO
DESTROY YOUR GENDER ROLES, SAYS
THE CIVILIZATION THAT HAS BECOME
MISERABLE BY DOING THE EXACT
THING THING.
YEAH, NO THANKS.
MAYBE THEY WILL TELL US TO KEEP
OUR MONEY.
BUT NO MATTER WHAT THEY SAY, WE
WILL NOT STOP SENDING THEM OUR
MONEY.
FOREIGN AID IS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE POSSIBLE WAY FOR THE
ACADEMIC LEFT TO EXPORT ITS
POISONOUS SOCIAL PROGRAM TO THE
REST OF THE WORLD.
THE ROMAN EMPIRE BUILD ROADS.
WE DEMAND POORER COUNTRIES
BECOME WOKE.
BEFORE LONG, OR AID BUDGET WILL
CONSIST ENTIRELY OF ADVANCED
WEAPON SYSTEMS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST AND
TAXPAYER-FUNDED GENDER
REASSIGNMENT SURGERY FOR AFRICA,
AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT WILL BE
HAPPY ABOUT THAT.
LINDSEY GRAHAM WILL CELEBRATE
IT.
BUT HOW WILL YOU FEEL ABOUT IT?
WELL, WHO CARES ABOUT HOW YOU